20 years ago they were seen as a bunch
of crazy inventors
now these dutch designers say they are
ready to fly if you come to a place
where you want to take off
it takes you about two minutes to change
it
to flight mode but long seemed a
futuristic idea is looking pretty real
on this dutch road
so far this flying car is only allowed
to drive the company hopes to get
permission from the european aviation
safety agency as early as next year
scientists long try to figure out how to
make a car fly
or a plane drive we have to be able to
fold
rotors propellers tails into a shape
where you can take it on the road
and that's very challenging especially
because it has to be light
so all these technologies are
incorporated in our design
and that's why we can build a flying car
now which we couldn't 10 or 15 years ago
although tens of companies worldwide are
developing innovative modes of
transportation
this company claims theirs is the first
flying car that will become a reality
dutch taxi companies have ordered three
it still feels like i'm playing a part
in a science fiction movie
and it's hard to imagine that i could
soon fly away with this car at least if
i would have the money to buy it
unfortunately the company wants details
kept secret and were not allowed
to film this car in action and skeptics
don't believe that we'll soon see
a sky full of flying cars yeah i'm
flying delorean car back to the future
this is not technically feasible
this is fantasy this pure fantasy
although palvey could soon be
technically feasible
aviation expert joris malker does not
see it as a new mode of transportation
this is a toy for very rich voice you
could
say and there may be some some niche
places where you can use this
special forces emergency aid
so there may be some niche products for
that but for you and me
no i guess i would have to ask for a
salary raise first
okay the runway is clear we have no wind
you are
go for landing instructors say it takes
45 hours to learn to fly the pelvi which
is based on a gyro plane a mix between a
helicopter and a plane
tomi van reyen is one of those who
ordered a half a million euro flying car
it's ultimate freedom for me so
i will use it for business in italy and
i also
use it for pleasure you know everybody
every young boy wants to be james bond
one day
and i want i'm one of them while for
james bond the imagination has no
boundaries in real life customers of the
dutch flying car will have to find an
airstrip first before they can take off
and land
step fasten al jazeera rams don't fear